[Musique]
je l'essaie des limites la musique fait
partie de la famille
[Musique]
fonctionne particulièrement il se
nourrit tes d'haïti il est né le sit in
des musées représente la misère de la
diaspora haïtienne elle a quitté haïti
avec deux valises une value pour rester
et mes valises pour retourner
[Musique]
la mère du chancelier a quitté haïti
rexie six enfants qu'elle a élevé seul
franz avait 8 ans quand il est arrivé au
québec
grandir dans une famille nombreuse a
forgé le caractère de l'ingénieur qui a
aussi cette demi frère et sa une grande
famille c'est faux que tu négocies peut
pas tout avoir alors ça m'a vraiment
aidé à
faire des choix rapidement de savoir
négocier puis tenir mon goût caen joue
dans le sens de l'église ils ont
maintenant père de trois enfants le
chancelier souhaite leur inculquer les
valeurs reçues en héritage le goût du
travail de l'entr'aide à la victoire à
ses couleurs des compétitions on joue
pour gagner veuillez accueillir
chaleureusement nos panélistes
franz un délit est une espèce rare
chercheur passionné d'intelligence
artificielle
c'est aussi un entrepreneur qui sait
faire multiplient lire vous j'ai un
curieux de nature j'aime les choses
compliquées complexe donc j'aime
résoudre des problèmes complexes donc ça
prend ça aussi ça prend un certain
certaines attitudes qu'amicale très
tenace j'ai pas peur d'eux d'échouer
d'essayer des choses qui devra commencer
leddartech est née justement de la
recherche on est une spin arche de lino
en 2017 il prend les rênes de leddartech
une entreprise issue de l'institut
national d'optique de québec qui
développe des micropuces et des capteurs
visant à rendre les automobiles autonome
le but réduire les accidents mortels
presque toujours provoqué par des
erreurs humaines si je peux vous équiper
dans votre cabine véhicule le dispositif
qui vous permet d'avoir une vision
périphérique 360 comprenez que le jeu
peut réduire énormément le nombre
d'accidents bénin depuis quatre ans le
nombre d'employés de leddartech est
passé de 30 à 215 personnes des
ingénieurs surtout et le chiffre
d'affaires a grimpé de 100 millions
après 2 milliards de dollars
il est parti d'haïti c'est des gens qui
n'avaient rien à l'arrêt devait
apprendre à survivre dans un pays voit
ce qui arrive ne connaissait pas le
français ni l'anglais je dresse une
question de bataille de résilience
quotidienne pour survivre à la si besoin
donc pour moi je pense que son
entrepreneuriat est venue est venue de
là
les juniors encourage chaque femme à se
lancer en affaires d'abord en design de
mode puis dans la production de
cosmétiques
ensemble ils ont fondé dans le quartier
saint-michel un incubateur d'entreprises
qui a des immigrants à devenir
entrepreneurs
et encore on le voit aujourd'hui dans
les nouvelles quand il ya quelque chose
qui est relié à la violence dans les
quartiers comme saint michel et mariama
ça prend des mesures donc et pas pour
banaliser ce qui se passe la violence
chez les jeunes mais on voulait changer
la rhétorique de l'idée de gangs de rue
à un groupe de développement économique
ça c'est un détecteur environnementale
inverse le chercheur est devenu riche en
vendant sa première entreprise qu'il
dirigeait en allemagne d'ici on met
vraiment à l'espace 37 37 c'est vrai
qu'il ya des activités de formation en
2012 il a investi pour rénover une usine
de textile désaffectée au 37 37
boulevard crémazie est à montréal que
dans le secteur des technologies
tellement de gens faisaient beaucoup
d'argent mais il se disait l'argent pour
s'acheter des yatchs des grosses
voitures des grosses maisons mais
au-delà de ça au delà de la grosse villa
au delà du gros bateau qu'est ce qui se
passe mais se disent mais je pourrais
peut-être utiliser mon argent à meilleur
escient donc à investir dans des
infrastructures qui vont peut-être être
des tremplins pour d'autres depuis sa
création il ya neuf ans l'écu batteur a
eu d'épidémie l'entrepreneur si je
regarde mon père mais il a toujours
redonner à son prochain avec zéro avec
hargne et mais c'est le même principe
donc j'aimerais pouvoir léguer sa
pouvoir partager mon expérience enrichir
les autres c'est un bien-être qui est
inexplicable n'ya pas sa pote ça n'a pas
de prix pour le nouveau chancelier
ce qui n'a pas de prix c'est la
gratitude de jeunes on vous l'a
interpellé pour le remercier merci parce
que savez quand on vient mort et
allemand on a le stigma de notre code
postal donc on a peur de dire qu'on
vient de brillamment et vous vous avez
pas peur de dire que vous avez vécu
entre un an à saint michel à rivière des
prairies ça nous donne espoir
pour moi ça c'est c'est probablement le
plus beau cadeau que j'ai pu avoir
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
des limites
[Applaudissements]
pour la première fois dans l'histoire du
québec une personne noire projet de la
collation des grades d'étudiants
universitaires d'un moment historique je
m'apprête à remettre des diplômes
année-là des docteurs et pour moi
représente
l'espoir il ya beaucoup de choses
sérieuses
commencent et
on a fait un test de l ap la personne
que tu admires
j'ai fait mon père je suis fier de lui
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]